GOOD MORNING THIS RULES
COMMITTEES CALLED THE ORDER
PLEASE BE ADVISED THAT AN AUDIO
AND VIDEO RECORDINGS BEING MADE
OF TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS IT'S
ALSO BEING TELEVISED SECRETARY
WILL YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
COOLEY CUNNINGHAM CORREA LARA A
SON. KAMLAGER MAIENSCHEIN
MATHIS QUIRK SILVA PROMOTION
RIVAS WICKS WE HAVE A QUORUM.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A QUORUM WE
ALSO HAVE A CONSENT AGENDA IS
OUR MOTION ON THE CONSENT
AGENDA MOVE BONUS CAMARGO DUB
SECOND BY MISTER RIVAS-
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I. CORREA
CORREO AYE FLORA FLOOR I
GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE KAMLAGER
KAMLAGER IRATE MAIENSCHEIN
MATHIS QUIRK SILVA. QUIRK SILVA
AYE RAMESH RAMESH I RIVAS RIVAS
AYE WORKS THAT MOTION PASSAGE.
THE MOTION PASSES- WE WILL KEEP
THE ROLE OPEN FOR MEMBERS TO
ADD ON UNTIL EIGHT. FIFTY NINE
TODAY PLEASE ALSO NOTE THAT THE
ASSEMBLY RULES COMMITTEE WILL
NEED TO HAVE A HEARING THE WEEK
OF JUNE TWENTY NINTH REFER
SENATE BILLS TO THE APPROPRIATE
POLICY COMMITTEES DETAILS ON
THE DAY IN TIME WILL BE EMAILED
AS SOON AS THEY ARE DETERMINED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.